What is model identifiability in Machine Learning?
A model is identifiable, if with
a sufficiently large training set,
we can rule out all but one
parameter setting of the model.
Non-identifiability is the opposite when
multiple equivalent models give the same outputs.
In a nutshell: There are many causes for
model non-identifiability: for example,
weight space symmetry, which happens when
we rearrange the hidden units and their
incoming and outgoing weight vectors accordingly.
We get technically a different model,
but one delivering the same output.
Model nonidentifiability could
cause infinitely many equivalent
model configurations and therefore
potentially infinitely many local minima.
But this is not THE big problem for non-convex
optimization because at least these local minima
have equivalent value, so the bad and the
good local minima proliferate all the same.